so hey everybody had a little Mike
trouble on this one sound quality is not
going to be up to usual standard sorry
alright what's the name of the
overplayed talking about I'm gonna have
to deal with free you're gonna be this
time oh that's nice that goes down a lot
better than when I try and do that with
hard alcohol cuz I'm too lazy to fill a
bottle with just something like water
hey everybody I'm not drunk I swear but
yes the trailer for frozen 2 has landed
and look the track record right now for
animated sequels at least from where I
sit is not great as far as recent memory
goes particularly when it is coming to
things coming out of the house of mouse
now how much you want to count
Incredibles 2 that depends I mean its
Pixar was just owned by Disney but that
is a different creative team than Disney
Animation proper now Disney Animation
proper did give us wreck-it Ralph to
which I did not care for and have been
thinking less and less and less of as
time has gone on so I'm not thrilled at
the prospect of a new sequel from
Disney's in-house animation team
especially when they were doing so well
with brand new properties up to this
point so I'm inherently gonna be a
little bit gun shy when it comes to this
entire prospect and when I looked at the
trailer for the first time I was kind of
expecting to see something along the
lines of the trailer for the original
which actually weren't that good theater
shows there was a big focus on Olaf
that's not to say I expected Olaf to be
front and center but I expected it to be
that kind of you know little continuous
scene that's probably not even in the
movie we're just you know there's
something we put together
for marketing and it's not that what we
got I would say is probably definitely
all stuff from the film the last shot
was the only one that made me go maybe
not but the rest of it is like yet no
that tracks that reads no dialogue
just moments music some moments longer
some moments shorter glimpses of the
characters we know a couple of very
quick shots of a couple of new
characters who I'm not even gonna
speculate who they are in terms of you
know connections to everything going on
and whatnot but when I watch it for the
first time I thought you know that's not
bad now watch it again and started
actually picking at and found myself
going mmm because my brain did that
thing that my brain does which is to
take whatever information it is that I
have at my disposal and then try and
figure out all the ways that this might
go wrong my brain I died tell you okay
so we start out with the rather extended
thing of Elsa trying to basically run
into the ocean now this is both a good
and a bad scene for the purposes of a
trailer I think I think it's good
insofar as her immediate goal and what
she's doing is clear and it does not
require the context of why she's doing
this for us
to get exactly what it is she's trying
to accomplish right now
um and so it works is in terms of a
build there's a certain sense of danger
when the ice breaks up and she's further
out you do get a sense of oh jeez so on
that level it works but on second
viewing it really does kind of make me
go wait wait a minute
um and again maybe with it with the
context of the film and knowing why
she's doing this it'll work better but
as a piece of marketing it doesn't hold
up to a lot of scrutiny because without
additional information
I'm forced to start asking questions
such as how is what she's doing here or
what she's trying to do here any harder
than what we already saw her doing in
the previous movie what I mean by that
is this is the sort of scene that would
have worked really well in isolation as
a piece of promo material if she had
ended the previous film either still not
quite control of her powers of having
like only accomplished so much with her
powers and if this was a demonstration
of like oh she couldn't do that last
time but everything we see her do here
completely fits with what we've already
seen her do and at the scale we've
already seen her doing I mean let's not
forget the woman built an ice palace and
she frozen it wasn't even a lake it was
like it was like an inlet or uh or a
lock I don't know what it was but she
froze the whole dang thing solid so the
idea of running on the ocean makes me go
okay that's not any harder than what
you've already been doing so then I'm
left kind of kneading the thing that
this lacks which is why and in the
context of the film that's gonna be what
makes or breaks the scene like that
because in and of itself which is how
it's being used as piece of marketing
yeah it doesn't quite work and we've got
you know shots of the various characters
we've got a more fairly somber tone on
this it's not um especially triumphant
so we don't the the opening stuff with
Elsa doesn't climax with her
accomplishing whatever it is she's
trying to do it climaxes with her
appearing to fail and there's a
surprisingly for a lack of a better
comparison Empire Strikes Back kind of
tone to this it has that feel of like
the the first age of Ultron trailer
where it's like yeah last time was fun
things are serious this time
which again strikes me as a little odd
because while I do like the original
frozen a lot and it is a lot of fun it
also deals with some heavy stuff it's
more
like fluff so that that tone I find it
interesting but I also have to wonder is
that your best angle then again maybe
it's just because the last taste people
had frozen was the Olaf's adventure
holiday thing that they very
ill-advisedly slept in front of cocoa
and I don't know if I if I really if I
talked about that one and give my review
of cocoa it's fine as a piece of media
but it's very obvious that it was made
to be a half-hour TV special but they
stuck it at the front of a movie to turn
an hour 40 minutes perience into a
2-hour one for a filming day dad
youngish kid that was just dumb and a
lot of people resent it so maybe that's
why they decided to move away from the
more whimsical thing because that one
was steeped in the whimsical end of a
frozen and they want to remind people of
the of the heavier more emotional stuff
again fairly context-free and there are
some interesting little moments I like
the emphasis on fall imagery of the
autumn season of the colored leaves and
you know sort of falling I mean I
autumn's my favorite season anyway so
I'm always kind of gonna be partial to
that so I may just be an easy target for
that but that didn't treat me I kind of
like the last shot that it that
basically Anna doesn't even hesitate to
draw somebody to draw Christoph's sword
and just swing it it's basically like
it's as if he was holding her purse he's
just holding the sword for her until she
decides to need it that was kind of
interesting it was all it was probably a
good idea to musically lean on the sort
of more chanting kind of stuff that was
used for the opening and closing parts
of the film because and this I will be
curious to see how they try and traverse
this possible pitfall
I don't know how much people realize the
success of let it go as a song and a
phenomenon contributed to the success of
frozen as a film now I don't want to
undermine frozen as a film frozen does
work as a film and it's not successful
because of that song but that song and
its ubiquity at the time really did help
thrust the film into the site into the
zeitgeist I think more than it would
have been otherwise I think it was it
was always gonna be a good film you know
you remove that song it's still a good
film it still got good characters with
good chemistry and interesting dynamics
and a great conclusion but you remove
that song and it doesn't quite have that
little extra to it and I suspect that
the makers of this are probably aware of
that and so they're left with one of two
options and I don't know which they'll
go with for the film itself but for the
purposes of marketing they made the
right one and what those two options are
is either try and capture that again
with a new song to basically be the new
letting go or to not even bother trying
to have a song of the same feel or vibe
or scale because they know they'll never
match it now
there's risk reward either way if they
make a new quote-unquote let it go even
if it doesn't get like say the radio
play that let it go did within the
context of the movie that will be a big
payoff because it will remind everybody
of you know that great moment from the
previous film and and with something new
that is reminiscent possibly even tops
it that's huge reward but if they swing
and miss if they come out with a song
that's very clearly trying to be the new
let it go and it doesn't quite work and
it is very clear that it it's just not
going to get there that's painful
and regardless of which option they go
with and the other one being like to not
even try and to do that means your other
stuff's going to be really solid and
peace some people are gonna go yeah
there really wasn't a song to match let
it go though and like that's just gonna
happen so there's risk either way but
we're gross of what
decision they made for the film itself
it was the correct decision to not have
any of the character singing in the
trailer because that really would have
made the comparison to let it go so at
the end of the day I'm a little bit
mixed on this trailer it's better and it
shows more potential I think
specifically in interesting ways than I
was expecting
because the thing is I think back on the
two most recent and at least as of the
this recording most recent animated
sequels to come out which were
Incredibles 2 and wreck-it Ralph 2 a big
part of the thing with both of those is
I I saw the trailers and went oh crap in
both cases I saw big red flags I don't
see big red flags here I still I can
still find stuff to be like that might
be a point where it goes off the rails
because that's just what I do but I'm
not seeing any massive glaring red flags
this time and I did with those other two
so with that in mind and just the fact
that the trailer didn't it didn't sink
me it didn't give me that oh god this is
gonna suck isn't it feeling that I had
where they just based off the trailers
of Incredibles - in wreck-it Ralph -
both of which were films I was
disappointed by and it appears to be
more so than than other people were but
there you go
so the the impression I'm ultimately
left with by this trailer is okay maybe
and given the heights that that previous
film a hit that's pretty solid for a
first impression so frozen - first
trailer you seen it what do you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it whole bunch of stuff to do
because there's buttons and links you
can like and subscribe you can support
me on patreon that'd be awesome
plus there's other links to check out
the besides other stuff I do social
media blah blah blah blah blah look down
in the description to see all that stuff
or don't cuz you know what at the end of
the day you're the council and me I'm
I'm just runnin the meetings and until
next time this council
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]